au sommaire ce soir la démission de
jacques crozemarie de la présidence de
l'arc l'interdiction par la justice que
la vente du livre de l'ancien médecin
personnel de françois mitterrand la
présentation par alain juppé à marseille
du pacte de relance pour la ville de 60
propositions un total look racing
déclare la guerre totale aux
indépendantistes tchétchènes et
l'élimination à melbourne
demain les pires ce qui avait remporté
l'an dernier ses internationaux
d'australie
madame monsieur bonsoir jacques
crozemarie a donc démissionné de ses
fonctions de président de l'association
pour la recherche sur le cancer la
gestion du fondateur de l'arc avait été
gravement mis en cause par la cour des
comptes et elle a entraîné l'ouverture
d'une information judiciaire
jean daniel flaysakier c'est par cette
lettre véritable plaidoyer pour sa
gestion que jacques crozemarie annoncé
aux membres du conseil d'administration
de l'arq qu'il était conduit à
démissionner le début de la fin c'était
le 3 janvier dernier où un conseil
d'administration exceptionnel avait été
réunie à la suite de fuites sur un
rapport de la cour des comptes
ce rapport mettait en évidence le rôle
étrange de certaines sociétés
fournisseuse de l'arc des sociétés à but
franchement le créatif depuis quelques
jours la justice s'intéresse à l'arc et
à ces sociétés françaises et américaines
une éviction sans doute intolérable pour
le président de l'association jacques
crozemarie a créé l'arc en 1962 il a
incarné personnifié à l'extrême il en a
fait la première association de ce type
en europe
son successeur sera connu dans les
prochains jours ni sur déjà deux trois
choses il ne sera ni médecin ni
chercheurs il devra être irréprochable
le juge des référés a interdit cette
après-midi la poursuite de la vente de
l'ouvragé du dr gugler sur la santé de
françois mitterrand la famille de
l'ancien président avait demandé la
saisie de cet ouvrage au nom du respect
de la vie privée et du secret
professionnel
dominique verdeilhan le grand secret
n'est plus à vendre après une nuit de
réflexion après une lecture de l'ouvragé
la justice a tranché tant pis pour ceux
qui ne l'ont pas acheter attend
désormais l'éditeur sera condamné à 1000
francs par ouvrage diffusé
la législation française est une
exception sur extrêmement porteuses et
sa maman protectrice de la vie privée en
l'espèce le tribunal a fait prévaloir
l'esprit cette législation sans tenir
compte du fait qu'il s'agissait du
président de la république et d'un
président qui avait fait paraître des
communiqués les manière régulière sur
son état de santé la justice condamne
fermement les révélations du docteur
gugler sur les circonstances du
diagnostic sur le combat physique et
morale du malade sur l'évolution du mal
et les traitements prescrits et dispensé
au président mitterrand décision prise
aussi au nom de l'atteinte à la vie
privée le juge parle d' intrusion
particulièrement grave atteinte d'autant
plus intolérable enchaîne le juge
qu'elle survient dans les quelques jours
qui ont suivi le décès et l'inhumation
du président mitterrand
bien sûr cette décision est rendue à
l'occasion de la publication d'un livre
qui concerne un ancien chef d'état
mais je pense qu'une telle décision
aurait pu être rendue au profit de
n'importe lequel d'entre nous auteurs et
éditeurs ont fait appel un appel non
suspensif
la justice se prononcera donc de nouveau
mardi prochain en attendant le livre est
interdite mais pas les magazines qui ont
publié les bonnes feuilles
je vous propose tout de suite d'entendre
la réaction du co auteur de ce livre le
journaliste michel gonnot qui a
recueilli des confidences du médecin de
françois mitterrand je suis atterrée par
ce que nous ne sommes pas condamnés par
la loi on ne nous sommes condamnés par
l'air du temps et l'air du temps nous
est défavorable
on nous accuse de ne pas avoir respecté
le délai de décence qu'il la respectait
depuis huit jours tous les journaux en
reprenant des extraits même devant sans
ce qu'il y avait dans ce livre 10
sensiblement la même chose ils n'ont pas
été poursuivis le livre l'est alors je
m'interroge pourquoi deux poids deux
mesures on n'ose pas saisir un journal
ont saisi 1
quiconque a lu ce livre se verra qu
absolument pas porter atteinte à la
mémoire du président nous restituant une
vérité qui a été dissimulée pendant 14
ans c'est tout la demande de saisie d'un
livre est très rarement accordée par les
tribunaux certaines interdictions
peuvent également faire l'objet de
décisions administratives de la part du
ministère de l'intérieur
le point avec fille boisserie cela
s'appelle le pilon les livres ils sont
condamnés à la disparition
la plupart du temps faute de lecteurs et
parfois parce qu'on ne veut pas qu'ils
trouvent de lecteurs parfois seulement
c'est très rare qu'on retire un livre de
la vente on peut très souvent exigée sur
plainte de votre soient concernés de la
famille ou d'amis ou quelqu'un de
famille plutôt de fac à vire des des
lignes ou des chapitres ou faire retirer
des pages ce qui est déjà assez fort
mais il est extrêmement rare depuis des
années en france on retire on suspend
d'un livre de la vente qu'on l'interdise
de vente octobre 86 le livre de bernard
violet démontre que l'agent secret nutt
n'a pas été assassiné mais s'est suicidé
pour raisons personnelles
révélation mais atteinte à la vie privée
résultat ils ont juillet 95 le livre
tintin et l'alcool déplaît à la veuve
d'hergé interdiction de vente avril
dernier une bible comporte des termes
jugés antisémites la justice interdit le
livre sauf si les termes sont supprimés
les interdictions ne viennent pas
toujours de la justice le ministère de
l'intérieur a aussi voix au chapitre
l'an dernier le livre blanc sur la
répression en algérie publié en suisse
par des proches du fils a ainsi été
interdit de publication
on était loin de la notion d'atteinte à
la vie privée une notion somme toute
assez peu utilisé en france mise en
vente il ya à peine deux jours ce livre
le grand secret a fait un tabac en
librairie alors comment réagit
d'éditeurs plomb à cette interdiction de
vente sous astreinte rappelons le de
1000 francs par ouvrage diffusé
christophe thorin les libraires n'auront
pas à retirer de la vente le livre du
docteur guillaume l'air les 40000
exemplaires mis en place hier ont été
vendus en quelques heures le grand
secret était puisée désormais interdits
à la vente les ouvrages continue
néanmoins à susciter un intérêt certain
je leur ai acheté oui mais
on en a suffisamment parlé les principes
aux pour qu'on sait c'est déjà assez
tous été retirés de la vente juste un
petit peu de moi choix d'autres au
contraire se félicite de cette décision
même scandaleux qu'il ait pu être mis en
vente une journée ce que je suis
absolument scandalisé par ce procédé je
trouve ça honteux qu'il a violé le
secret sans profession s'est il avancé
hierle ouvrage s'étaient arrachées dans
les librairies selon nos informations il
aurait été rédigé à partir de la mi
décembre et mis sous presse dimanche
dernier les révélations faites dans les
journaux sur l'état de santé de françois
mitterrand ont semble-t-il précipité la
parution je pense que la mesure n'est
pas adaptée au trouble si trouble il y a
le trouble qu'il soit bon qu'il soit
mauvais il est fait le livre a été mis
en librairie il s'en est arrachée
semble-t-il plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'exemplaires
très rapidement donc on va à nouveau
scinder le public en deux catégories
ceux qui auront eu accès à ces
informations
ceux qui n'auront pas eu accès à ces
informations la mise en garde judiciaire
est clair et net
interdiction de vendre le grand secret
sinon il en coûtera chaque libraire
mille francs de pénalité par ouvrage
le dr du blair a été entendu cet
après-midi par les policiers dans le
cadre de l'enquêté préliminaire ordonnée
hier par le parquet de paris
d'autre part le conseil national de
l'ordre des médecins a décidé d'engager
des poursuites à l'encontre de l'ancien
médecin personnel de françois mitterrand
pour violation du secret médical et non
respect de la vie privée la banque de
france a annoncé aujourd'hui une
nouvelle réduction des taux d'intérêt
avec la baisse d'un quart de point de
ses deux taux directeurs baisse permis
selon le gouverneur jean claude trichet
par la stratégie de stabilité de
crédibilité du franc france télécom a
annoncé aujourd'hui une hausse de 15% du
prix de l'abonnement téléphonique à
compter du 2 mars de 45 francs à 52
francs ttc
mais dans le même temps les tarifs
nationaux et surtout internationaux
devraient baisser
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
manifesté dans le calme ce matin dans le
centre de marseille
contre la politique sociale d'alain
juppé venu présenter son plan pour les
banlieues
les manifestants essentiellement des
fonctionnaires et des salariés du
service public ont défilé dans une
atmosphère bon enfant du haut de la
canebière au port de la joliette pour
présenter son pacte de relance pour la
ville alain juppé a donc choisi
marseille la ville dans le ministre de
l'intégration jean claude gaudin et le
maire tout au long de ce déplacement
dans la deuxième ville de france
le premier ministre s'est efforcé de
donner corps à la stratégie de proximité
préconisée par jacques chirac sur le
nouveau style super reportage carole
comme bernard connor proximité et
dialogue
alain juppé a choisi d'inaugurer dès
aujourd'hui sa toute nouvelle méthode
gouvernementale proximité avec cette
promenade dans les rues qui bordent le
vieux-port de marseille dialogue avec
cette visite dans un lycée professionnel
des quartiers nord de la ville à la
rencontre de ceux qui chaque jour se bat
contre l'exclusion en france c'est
parfois dur mais ça crée une taille très
très appréciable dialogue encore à
propos du grand sujet du jour le premier
ministre l'a réaffirmé à l'issue d'une
réunion avec tous les partenaires
concernés
le pacte de relance pour la ville
s'inscrit d'abord dans la concertation
pourquoi pacte j'ai beaucoup insisté je
crois que ça a été un des éléments du
succès de cette rencontre
il ne s'agit pas d'un plan clé en main
tout ficelé qui serait en quelque sorte
parachuté par le gouvernement à prendre
ou à laisser et d'applications
instantané les mesures présentées
aujourd'hui pourront donc être revu dans
l'avenir avec les différents
interlocuteurs politiques ou associatifs
des mesures d'ailleurs plutôt bien
accuse déjà reporté à trois reprises
rebaptisée pour la seconde fois le pacte
de relance pour la ville avait d'abord
été revue à la baisse ces derniers mois
assez pour faire douter de la volonté
politique du gouvernement de s'attaquer
à la fracture sociale
un doute ce qu'alain juppé s'est efforcé
aujourd'hui coûte que coûte de dissiper
ce pacte de relance pour la vie comporte
au total 68 propositions dont une
dizaine de mesures phares les moyens
dégagés pour l'ensemble de ce plan
s'élèvent à près d'une quinzaine de
milliards de fonds budgétaires sur trois
ans et 12 milliards de prêts à des taux
très avantageux
la thérapie 96 à destination des
banlieues s'appelle donc pacte de
relance pour la ville il s'en dégage
deux grandes idées d'abord le
développement d'un vrai secteur
économique dans les cités mise en place
d'une vingtaine de zones franches
l'exonération de taxe devrait attirer
des entrepreneurs cent mille emplois
nouveaux seront enfin proposés aux
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans mais l'état
s'engage aussi à revenir dans des
quartiers qui l'a parfois délaissés 2000
policiers supplémentaires seront donc
affectés en banlieue 50 centres pour
mineurs délinquants seront aussi créés
compte total de ce pacte 15 milliards de
francs sur cinq ans ce plan banlieues a
suscité des premières réactions plutôt
positives chez les organisations
professionnelles représentatives des
commerçants qui vont donc être aidés
fiscalement à se maintenir dans les
quartiers difficiles dans la cité de
monclar en avignon
beaucoup de commerçants préféré fermer
boutique et ceux qui sont restés
travaillent dans des conditions parfois
assez rude
reportage maryse burgot pascal cas
à l'entrée du quartier monclar une
boulangerie apparemment banale
apparemment seulement devant le magasin
12 clous en acier pour éviter les casses
à la voiture bélier une boulangerie qui
a en fait toutes les allures d'un
guichet de banque
ici c'est à travers des barreaux ou
faire le pain les jeunes est l'atout pas
bon mais ma perche est une figure il
s'est glissé là dessus bon mais ça
arrive à ce que celle-ci même d'attraper
le patron qui était juste à côté on n'a
pas rêvé d'une alarme mais j'ai sonné
bon en fait ils sont partis mais ça me
chante pas sur la 33e fois à deux pas de
là les propriétaires de la boulangerie
barricadés dans leur maison ils vivent
ici depuis 28 ans et ils ont vu leur
quartier change et se transformer peu à
peu en un ghetto pour chômeurs et pour
gens d'origine étrangère
si quand même chacun met un peu du sien
pour suivre tous ensemble il n'ya pas
c'est vrai mardi il y en a qui
détruisent madère alors bisous bien sûr
après on se retrouve enfermé sur nous
autres personnes et toute l'année on
importe qui fera passer sais pas
qu'est-ce qui viennent compléter la nuit
qui se plie vols de voitures
cambriolages agressions la délinquance
est une réalité sur le quartier
le sentiment d'insécurité est donc très
fort parfois disproportionnées par
rapport aux faits alors les commerçants
s'en vont le buraliste le teinturier le
patronat supérettes sont partis depuis
longtemps
restent ceux qui aiment la cité malgré
tout à l'image du pharmacien qui n'a pas
l'intention de baisser les bras et à
condition que chacun mette du sien et
que les par exemple les enfants qui sont
à l'origine c'est les enfants qui sont à
l'origine des dégradations et les ceux
qui sont un petit peu plus grand
les adolescents soient encadrés et bien
encadré et ne soient pas laissés à
l'abandon comme c'est le cas un discours
mal compris par les jeunes car s'il
admet les problèmes de délinquance ils
refusent en bloc les nages radicaliser
condamner leur quartier c'est l'image
qu'on donne du quartier ats je remonte
la pente à le traverser et pourtant là
j'ai des amis européens on va te laisses
aller chez des amis européens qui
viennent dans le quartier saint quentin
ils sont repartis avec la voiture ils
n'ont pas eu de problème en fait encore
vivre ensemble c'est ce que nous avons
été les commerçants et les habitants de
la cité
malgré les apparences fonds veut encore
croire ici à des jours meilleurs
les réactions des associations qui
travaillent sur le terrain sont plutôt
globalement positive à condition que la
volonté politique exprimée aujourd'hui
par le gouvernement soit confirmée dans
les prochains choix budgétaires jugement
un peu plus tranché pour le ps qui voit
dans ce pacte de relance un plan en
trompe l'oeil qui ne répond pas aux
besoins réels des habitants notamment
des jeunes sans emploi le jour même de
ce nouveau plan en faveur des banlieues
l'un des symboles d'une certaine
aberration matière d'urbanisme a volé en
éclats dans tous les sens du terme dans
la banlieue de nancy vous le voyez un
immeuble par 210 mètres de long sur
prêts étages a été détruit par 130 kilos
d'explosifs répartis en 12 s'en charge
une opération qui a coûté près de 3
millions de francs et qui s'est déroulé
sans incident cet immeuble ne pouvait
pas être réhabilité à moins d'investir
200 mille francs par logement à l'ouzbek
dans le nord de l'allemagne
neuf personnes dont trois enfants ont
péri et 35 autres ont été blessées dans
l'incendié d'un foyer pour étrangers en
instance de demande d'asile politique
incendie qui pourrait être d'origine
criminelle
trois jeunes allemands suspects ont été
interpellés à proximité des lieux cette
nuit peu après le début de l'incendié si
l'hypothèse de l'attentât est confirmée
il s'agirait alors du plus important
crimes racistes en allemagne depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale
boris eltsine a annoncé aujourd'hui la
guerre totale contre les
indépendantistes tchétchènes selon le
président
russ l'assaut contre le village du
daguestan est terminée quatre-vingt deux
otages ont été libérés dix huit sont
portées disparues selon moscou 150
pro-tchétchènes auraient été tués
pendant les combats
mais une partie du commando aurait
réussi à s'enfuir avec certains otages
tout de suite le point que notre
correspondant dominique derda comme s'il
fallait tirer jusqu'au dernier missile
pour qu'il ne reste vraiment plus rien
de pierre vaux maïs grillé les forces
armées russes se déchaînent ce matin au
coeur mais il est trop tard c'est un
village fantôme que bombarder pilonnent
les soldats de moscou les vivants son
parti n'en reste que les morts la nuit
dernière raconte cet homme qui a réussi
à s'enfuir les tchétchènes ont rassemblé
quelques otages ils leur ont ordonné de
porter sur des brancards les combattants
blessés et ils ont tenté une sortie à
travers les lignes russes
après des heures d'affrontements ils
sont passés mais à quel prix
la fusillade a laissé sur le champ de
bataille des cadavres par dizaines
difficile dans cet amas de chair de
distinguer le tchétchène du russe ou de
l'otage daguestanais à moscou boris
eltsine annonce que l'opération s'est
achevée avec des pertes minimum tant
parmi les otages que dans les rangs des
forces russes sans plus de précisions
selon lui 80 deux otages ont été
retrouvés dix huit seraient encore
portées disparues
salman radio iev le chef du commando a
probablement déjà regagné la tchétchénie
avec une trentaine de ses hommes
toujours selon les chiffres officiels
cent cinquante trois rebelles ont été
abattus 28 comme ceci fait précis mais
la vérité officielle tout au long de
cette sanglante prise d'otages fut le
plus souvent à des années lumières de
l'ariège
en représailles à cette offensive russe
un autre commando tchétchène a détourné
un ferry turc avec de très nombreux
passagers russes à bord et menace de
faire sauter ce bateau le ministre turc
de l'intérieur n'excluent pas désormais
une intervention armée
si at il dit si le commando commencent à
porter préjudice aux otages voyage vous
voyez sur ces images sur le pont du
bateau à des preneurs d'otage armé et
couverts de cagoule un mode aux sports
rapidement aux internationaux de tennis
d'australie
arnaud boetsch apparemment fatigué par
les mauvaises nuits provoquée par les
pleurs de son petit bébé a été sorti par
l'américain washington autres éliminés
de marque mary pierce la tenante du
titre sorti avant même les quarts de
finale c'est exceptionnel par la modeste
joueuse russe elena liptser steva 6 4 6
comme dirait françois brabant pour la
marie tout va de mal en pire ce des
tennis haut talon aiguille il n'y a
qu'un pas que je franchis allègrement
lors d'un défilé à milan sur les
nouvelles tendances de la mode masculine
la couturière londonienne katharine
hamnett a innové avec des mannequins
portant des costumes tout à fait
classique voiliers et des chaussures
nettement moins classique
cette toute dernière information avant
de vous quitter l'élection à l'académie
française aujourd'hui de l'écrivain
d'origine argentine hector bianciotti
l'information continue sur france 2
avant votre magazine envoyé spécial vers
21h nous retrouvons tout de suite jean
luc mano et alain duhamel qui reçoivent
ce soir